and finally my favorite topic which is
authentication and authorization and
this is probably one of those areas
which we encounter every day I'm pretty
sure all of us have used authentication
screens before you have we have logged
into different platforms you have signed
up into different platforms those are
basically called the authentication
flows and to summarize everything in two
sentences uh authentication can be
explained as something a mechanism to
assign an identity to a subject to say
in the technical terms and basically to
answer the question of who are you
authentication basically means who are
you in a given context in a given
context the context can be a platform a
operating system uh or your phone
anything this the answer to this
question the process of finding the
answer to the this question is called
authentication in the same way the
answer to this question which is what
can you do in that context in that
platform in that operating system all
your capabilities all your permissions
to say in the technical jargon those
things the process of finding the answer
of the question what can you do in a
particular context that process is
called authorization those are the two
sentence summaries of the whole topic
and this is what we are going to talk
about in this video and we'll dive into
different aspects uh different
components of authentication and
authorization basically have a general
high level and Technical understanding
of how it works what is the importance
what are the different things that make
up and build the whole authentication
and authorization flows and everything
surrounding it now before we dive in
let's have some historical context of
authentication so first we're going to
start with
authentication right and for
authentication let's have some
historical context of what was the use
of it how did we reach here and how did
we reach to the modern methods of
authentication so the story start
somewhere in pre-industrial societies
and here authentication was pretty
intrinsic uh by that I mean it was
implied so an identity of a person or a
subject was the same as the subject's
recognition and what that means is
someone someone who is already respected
in the community let's say a village
Elder could vouch for a person and Deals
whatever deals were made uh during those
times were sealed with a handshake uh an
act of symbolizing Mutual recognition
and agreement even though it was pretty
Elementary this method leveraged a form
of auth authentication based on human
contextual trust it was based on humans
right it was based on trust and that's
how people started the initial methods
of
authentication but as populations grew
interactions extended Beyond uh familiar
circles uh like Beyond this soci Beyond
this Village implicit trust mechanisms
fail to scale this cannot scale right
because this person who is this whoever
this is in the community the Elder
Village Elder that guy is not trusted in
all the communities in all over the
society in different different countries
or continents right this method cannot
scale so this marked the beginning of
his search for explicit authentication
explicit o initially we said this was
implicit o which is based on trust
people needed proofs of identity that
could function independently of personal
acquaintance independently of any person
and that led to that led to seals and
cryptographic era so by the medieval
period Society needed this is society
Society needed a system that scaled
Beyond personal recognition which we
talked about earlier just based on
people of trusted reputation who can
vouch for other people or other subjects
or other deals so Society needed a
system which is which can scale beyond
that and during those times people came
up with this system which is called a
seal it was Wax Seal people who have
watched different movies or series of uh
historical times you must have come
across this this is like some seal and
this was know attached to different
letters or different agreements as a
some form of authentication or you know
some form of agreement and it was one
form of early cryptographic mechanism a
seal uh which was of a unique pattern
and this is put on documents uh which
acted as signatures today we have
signature digital signatures and uh
handwriting based signatures this was
one kind of signature during the
medieval period and these seals function
as the first widely adopted
authentication tokens you can say these
were one kind of authentication tokens
during those times and they were kind of
a physical representations of identity
that relied on possession something you
have if you have this seal you have this
in your possession then you are said to
be authenticated and you can verify
yourself using those seals seals had
their vulnerabilities they were prone to
forgery uh marking the first recorded
instan of authentication bypass attacks
so we have in the modern times different
types of authentication attacks one of
those kinds is a bypass attack a bypass
attack basically means skipping the
authentication with malicious intents
forging these kinds of seals for
malicious intents was one kind of bypass
attacks during the medieval period and
this led to the evolution of more
sophisticated mechanisms uh including
things like uh water marks and encrypted
codes right used in different trade
documentation setting a foundation for
cryptographic thinking people started
thinking more about codes how codes can
evolve to prevent different kinds of
attacks and forgeries and frauds and
that led to the next era which was past
phrases and shared secrets so we can say
during the times of
Industrial Revolution during the of
Industrial Revolution a lot of progress
happened in terms of machines right in
terms of machines a lot of progress
happened and the whole world started to
change and at the same time at the same
time communication
systems also started to get upgrades
Communications systems also started to
progress they started to evolve into
more secure and more advanced form of
communications and during those times is
technology called telegraph was
introduced and Telegraph became a
critical infrastructure and with it came
the need for secure message validation
and operators whoever was operating
these telegraphs they used pre-agreed
pass phrases you can say you can call it
also password but there are some form of
pass phrases and that was an early form
of shared secrets and these pass phases
were the same as static passwords like
they are not dynamic they decided on one
static string one static password and
they used it as a pass among them and
that relied on the principle of we can
say
something you know earlier the principle
was something you possessed something
you possessed which was a wax seal a
some kind of token that you possessed
that you can show to verify yourself and
that got evolved into something you know
which is which is much better in terms
of security and that was one step into
the evolution of which in the modern
times you know as password that time it
was called P phrases and that that the
principle whole principle of
authentication changed into something
you know which is inside your brain or
in some form of communication either
written or verbal and after that we can
say we can skip all that to the modern
times of computation computation
computational architecture and all the
modern authentication that we know of
and the first form of computation which
you already know is main frames main
frames in the somewhere in mid 20th
century and and authentication entered
its first digital phase so in there is a
story called in
1961 researchers at mit's project Mac
they were working with something called
compatible time sharing systems also
known as ctss and they introduced the
concept of passwords for multi-user
systems basically they were trying to
come up with some kind of system which
will allow multiple users to use a
computer without Shar sharing the data
without sharing a users data between
each other between each other and what
they did was they stored password in PL
text which was in itself a very critical
vulnerability and that came into view
when one of them printed the password
file in plain text because you can it
was a plain text file you can print the
password and that was the time when that
vulnerability came into place and people
got aware of that and this incident the
printing of the password file this
incident marked the Genesis of secure
password storage mechanisms right now we
have this philosophy that password
should not be stored in plain text and
this incident of someone printing the
password file in a printer that was the
initial idea that motivated people to
the philosophy of storing passwords
securely and that led to different
Innovations like hashing that you use uh
pretty pretty frequently today to store
passwords in our databases and different
cryptographic algorithms which
transformed passwords into irreversible
fixed length representations so hashing
is basically cryptographically so you
can say there is some kind of algorithm
it does some kind of computation you
provide it a plain text uh string provid
it and in turn it returns you a hashed
string a hash string basically means it
has a computational algorithm it will
transform that string the plain text
into a fixed length the length won't
change it does not matter you provided a
three character string or a 100
character string the length of the hash
will stay the same depending on the
hashing algorithm and it will provide
you the same result for the same string
every time that was the promise of the
hashing algorithm so these kinds of
algorithms started to emerge during in
this era and authentication began to
align with the principles of
confidentiality integrity and
availability the core tenets of
information security and then in the
1970s an explosion in in cryptographic
research driven by the work of great
people like Whitfield Dey and Martin
Helman the people who have come up with
cryptographic algorithms their invention
of the Diffy Helman key exchange
introduced the concept of asymmetric
asymmetric cryptography enabling two
parties to establish a shared secret
over a untrusted medium that was the
first time asymmetric cryptographic
technique asymmetric cryptography became
the backbone of modern authentication
protocols all the protocols that we have
now those are all based on asymmetric
key cryptography and you they are also
called pki public Kee infrastructure
systems and this era also gave the rise
to protocols like karos which introduced
ticket based authentication and karos
relied on trusted third parties to issue
tickets that verified both the user and
service identity which is a precursor to
token based authentication system that
we have now and we will shortly look at
those token based authentication methods
right now we are just exploring how all
the dots connect together how the
historical context led to what we have
today led to what we use used today all
the different algorithms mechanisms
methods and standard practices moving on
if we go forward during around
1990s when the internet was growing a
need for scalable scalable
authentication methods was also Rising
simple username and password based
systems were not enough and they were
not strong enough against brute force
and dictionary attacks that are new
newly coming during those times and that
led to something called that we have MFA
which is multiactor
authentication so MFA came with the idea
of a combination of different principles
it combined let's say three things one
thing is something you know with
something you have with something you
are basically something you know can be
passwords or passwords or pins something
you have can be cards smart cards or OTB
generators right and something you are
that is your personal identification it
can be biometric data biometric data
like fingerprints or retina scans right
and MF came with this revolution of
combining different principles different
level layers of principles that provide
a combined security to all kinds of
authentication applications and because
of that biometric authentication emerged
as a groundbreaking development
leveraging pattern recognition
algorithms and statistical models to
identify users based on unique physical
traits however biometric systems
introduce challenges of false positives
negatives and uh template security so
that is also not enough biometric
security was not the on step solution
for all the problems that were emerging
during those times and after that you
can say we are finally into the modern
times modern times we can which we can
Call 21st century the time that we live
today and in the 21st century the rise
of things like cloud computing and
mobile devices and API based
architectures they demanded Advanced
authentication Frameworks none of the
above authentication methods or
Frameworks or principles were enough so
we needed more advanced more technically
robust implementations of authentication
and during and because of those Demands
a lot of different authentication
components or authentication techniques
emerged and among those we can say some
of the important things are o o o 2
these are the ones that we still use
today and these are the most popular
ones these are I'm just talking about
the different comp components of
authentication that we are going to
discuss soon another thing is
jwt's then we have zero trust
architecture we also have for
passwordless passwordless authentication
system like uh web authentication
eliminate passwords entirely relying on
public key and private key stored in
Hardware devices we'll discuss O2 n JWT
shortly and then this and this is the
time that we live now and this is what
the future looks like as of now during
the time I record this video we have a
couple of candidates for the future of
authentication world we have
decentralized identity decentralized
identity that that is created using
popular Technologies like blockchain
they they offer a they offer a lot of
features robust features for
authentication people are still they are
still in early stages now and people are
still experimenting they
are promising and a potential candidate
for future of authentication then the
second is behavioral
Biometrics we have this concept called
post Quantum cryptography so post
Quantum cryptography is basically the
idea that once quantum computers start
getting used heavily they are going to
break all the cryptographic algorithms
that we have now that provide the sense
of security that we have that our data
our passwords our sensitive data is
secure because of these algorithms we
have RSA and um different different
types of public key private key
algorithms that are very difficult to
break with the hardware with the
computation capability of systems that
we possess today so once quantum
computers get uh used heavily uh once
they get common enough all these
algorithms cryptographic algorithms they
are going to break because quantum
computers are very very very fast in
terms of what you have today and these
algorithms are not made for that this
concept called post Quantum uh
cryptography is basically cryptographic
techniques that are even secure for
quantum computers we already have some
algorithms as of my knowledge and you
can read up on that all in all this is
pretty much all the historical context
that we have of authentication in our
knowledge with that let's move on to the
technical part the interesting part that
you as a backend engineer should have
the knowledge of before I jump into
authentication I want to introduce three
components that we are going to discuss
again and again uh in this whole video
so I feel it's better to introduce them
right now before we start anything so
that you have some kind of context or
some kind of familiarity when you hear
them and these three are very important
in all the authentication on
authorization flows though they are
sessions J WTS
cookies and we'll discuss what are they
let's start with sessions when the web
started when the whole internet game
started
HTTP protocol that we have that we use
for our client server communication if
you have watched my HTTP video then
you'll understand what I'm talking about
HTTP emerged as the backbone of all the
commun communications between client and
servers and by Design by Design sttp was
stateless stateless stateless which
basically means HTTP treated every
request as an isolated interaction so it
did not remember what was what was your
previous request every request had
enough and all the information that the
server needed to perform the business
logic that's what it basically means for
a stateless protocol it has it had or it
has no memory of any past exchanges and
this was enough and this was ideal even
for the earlier web the web that we
started with which mostly consisted of
static Pages static images and data that
people mostly read about just you look
at a website you read something and you
move on rable data static data that we
can call and people did not need
continuity people did not need memory
between different requests that was not
a need when it was designed
however however when we evolved as the
web transitioned into Dynamic content
and it happened very soon and when it
evolved into Dynamic content the
statelessness statelessness of HTTP
became a bottleneck how because we had
different types of websites a highly
interactive websites websites like
e-commerce sites which need to remember
what are the items in your cart that is
one example of the interaction or How
could a user remain logged in while
navigating between different pages that
was another uh need and these questions
marked the beginning of stateful
interactions in the web stateful
interactions it was the need for
stateful interactions otherwise modern
websites modern needs of Technology was
not uh met that's why we needed the web
to be stateful which HTTP was not and
that's why the concept of session came
into play a session basically provided a
way to establish temporary server side
context for each user and it has some
kind of memory about the user that the
server can have to remember the user
when the user makes a request next time
so how did it work first part was
session creation when a user logged in
the server created a unique session ID
and it stored it along alongside the
relevant user data whatever the users's
role name whatever the data the server
needed uh to do different kinds of
operation again and again it stored it
with the session ID whatever the cart
items of the user is all those
information that the server needed
repeatedly it stored it in a persistent
store it can be a database or it can be
a redis store which is a inmemory uh
persistent store compared to database
which is a file based persistent store
so the server stored the session ID with
all the user data the cart items or
whether the user is authenticated or not
all these different kinds of information
with the session ID is stored in some
kind of persistent store and the second
phase
is the session ID this key unique key
was sent to the client which is a
browser the server is somewhere in the
remote it's it is somewhere in the cloud
and the session ID is sent to the user
which on a browser as a cookie we will
see what a cookie is but it is sent to
the user as a cookie and all the
requests and all the requests that the
client made after that after the session
being created included that cookie with
those requests so that the cookie can
have the session ID and using this
session ID server can fetch this
information all the cart items users
data from this persistent store it can
be redes or itav so basically this
session IDE enable the web to have some
kind of memory enable the servers to
have some kind of memory for the sake of
the user for the sake of the client and
in the third phase you can say these
sessions were short lift which means
they had an expired date so let's say if
the session's expired date is 15 minutes
so after 15 minutes the user sends this
session ID to the server and they are
expired so the server creates another
session and sends the session ID stores
the user data in the persistance store
and that's how it works again and again
that's how this whole session thing
works and initially initially sessions
started with file based sessions those
were the early session implementations
and that stored data in files on the
server even though they were simple that
approach suffered from scality issues as
the number of users grew and server
started to implements implement database
packed sessions to handle large user
bases and to make the server scalable
sessions data moved to databases which
provided faster lookups and persistent
storage across server restarts that data
stored in the databases and even though
the server restarted the session became
available the session stayed available
to the server and eventually we remove
we move to distributed architectures and
during this era the session storage the
persistent Store where the servers
stored the sessions and the users
information move to distributed storage
distributed storage like that we have
redis which is a inmemory store inmemory
store basically means storing data in
Ram compared to hard disk that's a on
line explanation or mcast which is also
another in memory store and servers
started to use these these were
comparatively faster as compared to DB
lookups because they were in memory
stores so that's how of the uh storage
evolution of sessions happened and we
still use sessions even today for the
same purpose to provide some kind of
memory to our servers moving on then we
have is jws and this is a very popular
technology in the current times these
are very popular and we will see why
they become popular what are the
advantages that they offered as compared
to our traditional session based uh
authentication approach what are the
additional benefits of using jts that
cause their popularity so continuing our
earlier session discussion by the mid
2000s by the mid 2000s web applications
grown into globally distributed systems
and stateful systems stateful systems
even though they were effective they
caused a bottle link because first thing
memory maintaining session data for
millions of users became costly so we
right now we are talking about what led
to the emergence of gilies so first
thing is retaining session data for
thousands and millions and billions of
users became a large overhead for a lot
of servers second thing is
replication what this means is in
distributed architectures synchronizing
session data across servers or regions
one server could be in one part of the
World another server could be in the
opposite part of the world so
synchronizing the user data across these
servers from different regions introduce
latency so the authentication flow
introduced latency which is basically
means delays in authenticating the user
and consistency challenges because of
the synchronizing need and that led to
the birth of
gwts
JWT because developers sought a solution
that could offload state from the server
while maintaining security and integrity
that's what people came up with jws jws
which were formalized in the
2015 were a stateless mechanism
stateless this is the word to focus on
stateless there is stateless mechanism
for transferring claims we'll see what
claims are shortly transferring claims
in a stateless manner between different
parties let's say two systems
transfering claims in a stateless manner
between two parties or two systems and
the key Innovation here was
selfcontained JWT s
selfcontained tokens JWT tokens contain
user data stuff like user ID their role
and the cryptographic signatures in one
token which are base 64 encoded if we go
to the website called JWT doio
we can take a look at what a JT looks
like okay so this is what a JWT looks
like this is the whole base 64 encoded
JWT string and JWT has three parts so to
get a high level idea we can look at the
parts which are first part is the header
the header basically specifies metadata
metadata such as the signing algorithm
which can help uh the server to get some
information on what was the signing
algorithm that is used while the J was
being created so the first part the
header basically contains metadata about
the JWT itself stuff like the signing
algorithm and the second part which is
the payload data the data of the user
the data that we store in the JWT the
data that we actually need this also has
some kind of format that we typically
follow so the first thing is Sub sub is
the field where we usually store the
users ID we store the user ID and the
user ID can be in any context it can be
user ID uh from your database it can be
user ID from an au provider it can be
any user ID from any context this is
just a storage mechanism right you store
the user ID of the user in the sub field
in the IAT field this stores when the
JWT was issued that is the information
the I field stores which means basically
means issued at that's the full form of
IAT and then we have optional Fields you
can store the name of the user and the
role of the user whether the user is an
admin is a member or it is a role of
editor or a viewer or writer whatever
the role is you can store information
like like that different kinds of
information in different kinds of fields
inside the payload this is the part
where you can store information and the
last part is the signature of the JWT to
verify that whether you are the one who
issued it whether this data has been
tampered or not right and you can do
that with a secret key that you can
generate and keepy for yourself only you
have an access to it if someone makes
any change to the JWT and you verify
that JWT with your secret key then the
validation will fail because someone
made some changes to the JWT and it is
not tamper proof anymore and now you
know that so that is not a JWT valid JWT
anymore that's how you can verify users
data in in a stateless manner now you
don't have to store the session
information anymore whole session
verification mechanism just became
stateless it it happens with every
request it is very lightweight and saves
a lot of storage cost so these are the
advantages that jws offered that made a
lot of things in the authentication
workflows very simple the first thing
was
statelessness which basically enabled no
server side storage costs second thing
was scalability
scalability scalability basically means
a lot of servers these days use the
microservice architecture and
distributed architecture and which means
a cookie issued from one server cannot
be used for a server which is in another
domain as a in a microservice
architecture so using technology such as
JWT enabled a client to send the JWT to
different different servers and all the
servers will have the secret key of the
JWT using which they can decode the jwd
and verify the users's identity for now
a lot of servers a server can be scaled
to a lot of instances and they won't
have to worry about user authentication
anymore all the servers can do the user
authentication at the same time using a
shared secret key and that was one of
the major benefits of gwts which and the
third thing is the portability and
because because of the lightweight
nature because of the URL friendly
nature because of the base 64 encoding
string format jwt's could be passed
between different systems they could be
stored in local storage even though you
should not do that they should they
could be stored in cookies and a lot of
different Limited Space storage systems
they're very portable you can send them
in url values and a lot of other
advantages that JWT is offered in terms
of portability and on top of that they
also introduced some challenges One
Challenge was token the the of token
since JWT was stateless it was stateless
there was no stored mechanism that the
server used to uh validate the user's
identity if someone has access to your
JWT now they can impersonate as you they
can use your JWT to perform actions on
behalf of you that is the one
disadvantage of gwts and there is no
mechanism from the side to invalidate
that token until it expired manually
unless unless the server changed its
secret the secret using which the server
verified all the users now the problem
with that is if the server changes the
secret to invalidate one token now all
the users of that platform of that
system will have to login again and get
new jws just because the server wanted
to in validate token of one user that
was one thing second thing was
revocation so for some reason if the
server wanted to to revoke some users
access or some users uh access to the
platform or access uh in different
systems the server could not do that
because jws since they are stateless you
have no way to track the status of a JWT
token until they are expired you cannot
really do anything so these are the two
major dis advantages that came up
because of jts because of the use of jws
even though these days we found some
kind of solution for that for example
for the first thing and the second thing
together we use a hybrid approach of
using gwts so using a hybrid approach
again raises some questions first I'll
tell you what a hybrid approach is which
he came up with to beat the above two
advantages so this is how it works the
user logs in and the server sends it a
token a JWT token which the user stores
in its system okay and with every
subsequent request to the server the
user sends a JWT in either a
authorization header or in any other
form or a quicky or anything okay and
that's how the server gets the JWT it
verifies the JWT with its secret key and
make sure the user has proper uh access
or it can identify the user that's how
it works in a JW
based workflow so in the hybrid approach
what we do is we combine statelessness
with statefulness what that means is in
a jwd typical workflow we don't make an
additional lookup in our storage the
storage could be a database lookup or a
inmemory lookup like redis or mcash we
don't do that we verify the JWT with a
secret key and we find out who the user
is using the user ID that is stored
inside the J WT that's it we don't do
any additional storage lookup now in the
hybrid approach what happens after you
verify the gwts after you uh have the
verification step passed you maintain a
blacklist of gwts in your persistance
storage again it could be a database
call or a inmemory call for redis or
mcast and using that you can temporarily
block some users revoke access for some
users uh in case of some users account
being hacked or some user doing some
malicious activity you can temporarily
block their access using a blacklist now
the question it raises is the whole
point of using JWT was the statelessness
and if you are doing a persistent
storage lookup for checking the validity
of the jwd why not do the statefulness
why not do the stateful approach in the
first place which can provide this
advantage and it is considered more
secure so these are the kinds of
questions that we frequently see uh in
the industry typically the advice is
don't think about all these different
authentication strategies and all go
with a Au provider we have a lot of
different different types of
authentication providers we have ozero
we have the modern Alternatives like
Clerk and all that's their headache
that's their headache to worry about
what technologies what components of
authentication to use which is more
secure which is a more secure way which
are more secure techniques and
everything the starting from the
algorithm to Hash to salt all the
different parts all the different
headaches of authentication which which
creates a secure authentication system
that's their headache it's very
important if you are building a medium
to a largly complex system it's a good
idea to go with an external o provider
even though it's it's a good idea if
you're learning backend engineering to
implement your own o understand how the
different parts work and understand the
tradeoffs understand the advantages and
disadvantages everything after that in a
production system go with au provider go
with an O provider unless you're very
confident about your authentication
workflows okay that is my two sents
about what you should do with all this
confusion about what is right what is
not and all and the third thing that we
have is Cookie and we have already
discussed and talked about using cookies
in in the earlier two examples for
example in the session based
authentication uh first I'll explain
what a cookie is Cookie is basically
some way of storing a piece of
information it can be any string any
value it is one way of storing this
information in a user's browser from the
server side that is the important part
using cookies using cookies servers now
can store some information in client
browsers from this side so this is a
very nice features uh offered by
browsers so using the HTTP request
workflow a servers can store some kind
of information in the users browser
given given certain conditions
conditions that that cookie is only
accessible to that server a server
cannot see other servers cookies so that
is a nice feature that is a nice
security feature offered by the browsers
so using this whole mechanism cookies
and all a cookie set by one server in a
client's browser will be sent in all the
subsequent request to that server so
this whole Workplay of cookies the
server storing the cookie in the users
browser and the cookie being sent to the
server with every subsequent request
from the users browser this whole
Workplay enables that during the
authentication workflow so let's come
here during the authentication workflow
first a user a client authenticates with
username and password to the server to
the server and if the authentication is
successful the server sets a cookie we
can say a cookie with the authorization
token this looks something like V A JWT
token or a session ID it can be whatever
depends on the implementation it stores
it in the client's cookies and in
subsequent request the client's browser
it can be Chrome Firefox Papa whatever
it is tends this information this cookie
key to the server so that the server can
validate authenticity of the token and
it can authorize it can it can identify
the user and it can authorize the user
and do all the uh workflows that comes
after the authentication so cookie is a
very nice way to automate the process of
server uh sending the token to the
client and the client sending the token
back to the server with every subsequent
request all of this can be done from the
server side using the mechanism called
cookies because the server has access
access to client cookies that is stored
in the browser from the server side that
is the part to focus on and that was
about three major components of modern
authentication now let's move on to
different types of authentication types
we pretty much already have discussed
what are the two major types of
authentication but here we can keep that
as a topic at hand and discuss them at a
very high level the first part
is stateful authentication and the
second is stateless we have also other
methods of authentication we have API
key based authentication we also have o
2.0 based authentication and these are
pretty much all the major types of
authentication that I can think of that
we use as backend engineers in our
day-to-day lives okay let's dive into
each of these types and see how they
work and what are the advantages
disadvantages
and when should you use which one and
everything about them pretty much okay
let's get into stateful authentication
first one is a stateful okay all in all
this is what stateful authentication
typically looks like okay we have client
here it is a browser let's say it is a
browser it's a chrome we have the client
here client and we have the server here
okay first step
during authentication the client sends
username and password to the server
username or password or email or
password whatever the authentication
mechanism is to the server the server
checks the validity and the correctness
of the password and the username on the
email and all if they are correct if the
user is eligible to authenticate into
the platform the server generates a
session ID we have talked about sessions
already and this workflow also already
but let's just discuss it again a
session ID and the users data whatever
it is and bundle s user data bundles
them and stores in redis it can be a
database also but mostly platforms use
redis because of the fast read time Fast
Access time of the redis as compared to
our traditional databases okay and it
stores in the redis and it sends the
session ID back to the client back to
the client in a cookie in a cookie
stores it inside a cookie a HTTP only
cookie which means JavaScript cannot
access the cookie JavaScript cannot
access the value of the session ID and
the server sends the session ID to the
client back in a cookie and because of
the nature of the cookie because of the
nature of the subsequent request
attachment quality of the cookie what
happens is all the request that happen
after that one will have this cookie
where where the session ID is present
and the server will get this cookie the
server will take that session ID and it
will check the existence of that session
ID in redis the expiry of that and the
user data and everything and it can
identify the user it can authorize the
user or whatever it wants to do and the
user can has the ability to call the API
that's how the typical stateful
authentication workflow works and the
session ID can be any cryptographic
random string it can be JWT token
whatever it depends on the
implementation and that's all about
stateful authentication moving on to
stateless authentication that's
stateless and this is how stateless
authentication works we have a client
again we it's a browser and we have a
server the user sends the username or
password the email and password and
password in the first request while the
user is trying to login the server
checks the authenticity of the username
and password and if they are correct if
they are correct the server generates a
signed JWT token sign JWT token with a
secret key the server has its own secret
key using which it can sign gwts and it
can verify gwts this is very important
it has to be stored somewhere securely
so that it can sign or verify jws and
the server creates a new JW token which
has the users information things like
user ID user role Etc and it sends the
JWT back to the client okay then in all
the next requests if the client wants to
identify itself it wants to authorize
itself what it can do is it can send the
JWT back in a header you can send in any
way but the standard is you can send in
a header called
authorization and you paste the jwd here
and you send it to the server the server
extracts this token and it tries to
verify it using the secret key that it
has and it verifies it and then it can
find out the user's ID and if the
verification is successful the
authentication is successful and the
user can uh have a successful API
response otherwise the Ser will throw an
error called unauthorized or forbidden
or whatever the convention is and that's
how a stateless Authentication works
because because it's called stateless
because in a stateful authentication we
need to look up a persistent store it
can be a database or it can be red and
in a stateless authentication whatever
information that we need about the user
is stored in the token itself in the JWT
token itself which is a signed token
which is a signed token and to verify
the authenticity of the token we have a
secret key so it's a self sustainable
self containing token which has the
users information that's why it's called
a stateless token or a stateless method
of authentication now when should you
choose which one so to answer that you
have to understand the pros and cons of
both the different uh kinds of
authentication mechanisms in a stateful
authentication system the pros are you
have the pros
are first you have centralized control
you have centralized control control
over all the sessions you have real time
information of all the active sessions
of your users right because you have a
persistent store to verify to get that
kind of information and using that you
can easily revoke access of a user you
can revoke a session you can log out a
user because you have the session you
have the control in your hands and it is
well suited for applications with modern
traffic and strict session requirements
and in my opinion most applications
should go with a stateful authentication
because because of the secure nature and
the convenience of revoking tokens and
revoking access of users and having
real-time information about all the
users access and the challenges of a
stateful authentication is of course uh
The Limited scalability issues and the
higher operational complexity with
distributed systems when you have
multiple servers in multiple regions and
all you have latency issues and all so
those are some of the challenges of
State full authentication in large
systems in the same way a stateless
authentication has Pros the cons of
stateful authentication are the pros of
stateless authentication the pros like
scalability and no session store
dependency and it's ideal for
distributed architectures and mobile
friendly applications where cookies are
not a thing and all those cons of
stateful authentication are the pros of
stateless authentication but the cons
are here is token revocation is complex
and that is one major issue that once
you issue a jwd token until it expires
you have no way of uh revoking access of
that user um and it could be due to
various reasons because the user account
might get compromised and the user
contacted you using your support
channels that the user wants to revoke
that session the user wants to uh stop
access to their account so so you don't
have any way of doing that apart from
changing your secret key of the JWT
which will make all the users of your
platform to log out which is a serious
inconvenience so what can you do in this
Cas is you can device a devise a hybrid
approach where the main web app the main
web app which runs in a browser you can
choose stateful authentication for those
clients you can have a hybrid approach
where you authenticate your browsers
your web apps using a stateful nature
and the servers uh and the clients that
use your apis in mobile apps where uh
mobile apps or third party Integrations
between different servers they can adopt
a stat stateless authentication for
scalability and simplicity so you can
have a hybrid approach like this to beat
the cons of both the authentication
methods and now the third type of
authentication method that we can
discuss is API key based API key based
authentication K us to a completely
different set of use cases as compared
to the stateful and stateless
authentication so the primary reason
people came up with API key based
authentication and before we get into
that let me explain how it works so this
is how it works uh you go to a platform
and you have access to the platform and
you in the UI what you do is you go and
click on generate an API keyy okay you
can generate an API key uh then you will
get an cryptographically random string
uh cryptographically safe random string
some some some string and you can use
that string to gain access to the server
which caters to this UI okay this server
which is responsible for this UI now you
can directly gain access to this server
using this API key this is primarily why
people with the concept of API keys so
to give you one example everyone is
familiar with the interface of chat gbt
right so in chat gbt you can open and
you can type something in the search bar
and you'll get an response you'll get a
response that is the UI okay that is the
UI that we interact with but to cater to
that UI there is somewhere in in the
cloud not one server there are a lot of
servers those are the servers that are
responsible to send the response
back to the client and the client
renders that text in your UI in a very
nice userfriendly way so that you can
read and you get what you are looking
for that's how the typical interaction
works but open AI the company that
created chat GPT they also have feature
called API keys keys and why do people
use that so that people who don't want
to use chat gbt people who have
different use cases of the the model the
llm model uh that powers chat gbd it can
be any model GPT 4 GPT 3.5 and all they
want programmatic access to the server
they want to let's say they might want
to create a different UI for their use
case and they want the servers response
the chity server response in that UI how
can they do that or they want the
service response the response of jat gbt
programmatically in their server they
don't want their UI they are building
some server they want the response of
open AI uh chat GB and different models
in the server programmatically okay not
in terms of UI they need access in terms
of programs for these kinds of use cases
to provide access to your server not
your UI not your platform to provide
access to your server to a different set
of users in a confined manner in a
permission based manner in a expiry
based manner to provide that kind of
access people have come up with API keys
so that I can use this key whatever key
that has been generated with some set of
permissions some set of expiry dates I
can use this key and I can attach this
key in some way in headers or depending
on the server's implementation I can
send this key back to the charity server
whatever ever the server that has
provided me with this key and I can do
all the operations that the servers
native platform can do I can also do
using the apis okay I can get the access
to the server using the API key that's
the primary use case of API keys and
people have come up with it for
different different advantages first
thing is uh they are easy to generate
easy to generate you just go to the UI
you click on generate and that's it you
get an API key and you can use that API
key to grammatically access the server
second thing they are ideal for machine
to machine communication what machine to
machine communication means is what we
generally see or what we generally use
is client to machine communication what
you can say client to server
communication here we have a UI we
interact with our Mouse we interact with
our keyboard we interact visually with
the server right with the UI and the UI
sends programmatic requests to the
server and the server does the business
logic and sends a response back and the
user renders those information renders
those responses so that we can
understand and we can again uh interact
with it that's how the interaction works
it's visual interaction it's client uh
it's it's human interaction there is
another kind of interaction which is
called machine to machine interaction
machine to machine interaction so let's
say I have a server okay I have a server
which to which I have a UI here for my
platform and this is the server for my
platform and this server
wants to use the chat gpts capabilities
so let's say in my UI the user types
something some string and the US send a
request to my server and says summarize
this for me summarize this paragraph for
me what I want to do I want to use the
existing capabilities of chat GPD server
so that I can summarize that paragraph
and send it back to the user now this is
called a machine to machine
communication because my server visual
machine there is no UI here there is no
human interaction here everything is
done programmatically I have written
code here in whatever programming
languages and that's how the server is
running so This Server uses the API key
that I have generated using chat gbt's
platform uh interface my server using
this API key to make a request to the
chat JD server and it identifies uh my
identity it it authorizes myself the my
identity whatever plan I have whatever
uh
quot I have remaining whatever access I
have using this API all this information
is maintained in the server site chat GT
server and they can identify they can
find out that those information using
the API key okay and I can use this key
and I can get response from the chaty
server and I can send the response back
to my UI so this is how a machine to
machine interaction looks like I can use
my server to make request to other
servers and get that response so it is
different from like visual interaction
or human interaction or uh UI to machine
interaction API keys are ideal for these
kinds of interactions because if because
if you imagine in a typical in our
stateful or stateless uh based
authentication methods we need visual
triggers we need human triggers because
there is a login form where we manually
have to type it out the username and
password after to send this request
there is uh some server validation
happens and the server sends back a GWT
token and you have to save that suar and
all these complex interactions require
some kind of human interference and
that's why they are called client to
servey interaction and in the machine to
machine interaction the a simple
workflow is you provide the machine a
secret key it saves that in whatever
environment variable or some kind of
Secure Storage and it sends that in all
the requests to identify itself instead
of doing all the username password token
and all those workflows and API keys are
ideal for those kinds of interactions
for programmatic interactions or machine
to machine interactions now let's get
into our last major type of
authentication which is O 2.0 or open ID
connect whatever it is called okay why
do we need this why did we come up with
it and everything surrounding it up
until now up until now we have discussed
different types of authentic State pull
and stateless and API keys and all we
have a very simple setup right right we
create an account with uh username and
password and every time you have to
provide that authenticate yourself and
you get a token and you return all and
that's how the whole workflow works and
the more platforms you visit the more
sites you visit in your computer in your
system the more credentials you create
the more credentials you have to
remember or the more credentials you
have to maintain if you use a password
manager this approach became a little
problematic why first thing is security
risk reusing password was very common uh
during the initial era now I hope people
have become more aware of this and they
use uh automatic password generators and
password managers to maintain their
passwords but during the initial
internet era reusing passwords like 1 2
3 4 5 or the string password was very
common and a single breach compromised a
lot of accounts the first thing with
this password based approach was Secure
risks reusing the same kind of passwords
in multiple platforms or multiple
websites the second thing is
fatigue all this huge number of accounts
to manage was very overwhelming for a
single user and that gave rise to what
we call it's a very important Concept in
oath is called delegation Del sorry
delegation what delegation means is we
quickly came to a class of problem a
problem for example
websites one website started needing
access to other websites resources for
example a travel app a travel app like
uh a hotel booking or a train booking
app it needed access to access to Gmail
your Gmail account to scan your flight
tickets to programmatically scan your
flight tickets that is one example of
one platform one website needing access
to resource of other platform the same
way a social media app it can be
anything Facebook or Twitter or anything
there social media app that wants to
import contacts contacts from other
platform it it can be another social
media platform or it can be your Google
contacts anything right it wants to
import Resource One platform wants to
import resource from another platform
programmatically see now you see the
pattern this was a problem that this was
a use case that we started to see uh
which eventually uh gave rise to W so
initially what happened was the initial
solution that people came up with this
issue of how one platform or one website
can get get access to resources of
another platform this is how you just
use users came up with the solution they
what they did was they shared passwords
they started sharing passwords and this
was disastrous this led to so many
disasters because sharing a password
meant giving full access giving access
to everything in your account everything
in your system and there is no way to
limit permissions and the second thing
was it was impossible to re roke access
it is impossible to revoke access
without changing your password
everywhere since users used passwords
same passwords everywhere and providing
your password to one platform so that
that platform can access the resource of
another platform meant if you wanted to
revoke the access permanently from your
side you have to change your password
not just in this side you have to change
your password from all sides because now
one platform has access to your password
and it can do anything it wants which is
a huge security issue that came up with
this solution of sharing passwords for
giving platforms access to resources of
another platform okay that was the
solution people came up with initially
right now we have a problem that we
called delegation problem a delegation
problem which basically means providing
access of one platform to another
platform providing resources of one
platform to another platform
programmatically by a user and that was
the time in 2007 the birth of O happened
which basically meant open
authorization and it was not just a
protocol it was a very revolutionary
idea it it it it made so many things
easier so many things easier in our
programming world that we have now so
historically what happened was a couple
of engineer
a couple of Engineers from companies
like Google or Twitter started working
on standardizing a way so that users can
access user can share access from one
platform to another platform which is
the delegation problem and what they did
was they were trying to find a way to do
that without sharing passwords which was
a huge security risk so they came up
with a technique of sharing
tokens sharing tokens to share access
the idea was this token has specific
permission so a password has all the
access to your user account while a
token has specific access to a specific
part of your account for example if you
share your Google password with me I can
I can I have access to everything I can
view your Google photos I can see your
Google Maps history and I can look at
all your contacts and I can um see your
your calendar I can add to your calendar
I can remove everything I delete
everything I can do everything I I can I
want using that password but let's say
if you share a token and that token only
has capability to read my contacts okay
not delete my contacts not add to my
cont Del my contacts now I have
permission for a specific part of a
specific platform that you access that
you have that I can access now I can
read your Google cont tax so that was
the idea that they came up with sharing
tokens instead of passwords so there are
different components uh of the technique
that they came up with first was the
resource owner the second was the client
third was resource server and the fourth
was authorization server and first thing
who is the resource owner the user who
owns the data so in this case let's say
it's you you are the resource owner who
is the client the app that is requesting
access for example we have a uh social
media app let's say it's Facebook and it
is requesting access for your contacts
from your Google account so in this case
client is your client in this case is
Facebook who is the resource server in
this case it is your Google account
which is the Google server the resource
server is the authorization server this
is the server who issues the token the
token for authenticating the user this
is the token that is issued by the
authorization server after
authenticating the user so this is how
the typical flow of O 1.0 look like so
we are still talking about wor 1.0 we
will we are yet to reach the wor 2.0
which came after this for a couple of
reasons that we'll discuss this is what
the what 1.0f flow looked like first the
client redirects the user redirects the
user to the authorization server OD
server okay redirects the client to the
OD server the client the client who is
the client in this case it is Facebook
Facebook redirected you to the
authorization server now what happens
next the user authenticates and grants
permission you click on yes I allow and
these are the permissions that I want to
give this server and you do that after
that is successful in the third step the
authorization server the server that you
authenticated that you give all the
permissions to that authorization
servers sends token to the client client
who is this client in this case it is
Facebook it sends the token to Facebook
now the client uses the token whatever
token it got from the authorization
server it uses the token to access the
resources what is the resource in this
case your context which is in your
Google server so that's how Facebook a
client get access to another platform
which is Google in this case another
platform's resource which are contacts
in this case programmatically without
you sharing the password with specific
set of permissions so oath 1.0 solved
this problem in a very beautiful way
which eradicated the problem of sharing
the password to share access but then
the oath 1.0 protocol evolved and we
ended up with oo 2.0
which came around 2010 or so oath 1.0
was pretty revolutionary it was pretty
useful but it had some limitations one
of this was it was one of it was it was
very complex for developers to implement
the whole flow was pretty complicated
for developers at that time second it
used cryptographic signature it used
cryptographic signatures which was very
error prone so these are the two
limitations technical limitations that
what o 2.0 did was first thing it
introduced beer tokens which is much
much much more simpler in the whole o
workflow it is more vulnerable but it
made implementations more simple second
it allowed developers it allowed
developers to choose flows based on the
app type depending on whether the your
app is a mobile or it is a server side
app or it is a device only app or like
for example device code app for example
Smart TV depending on different
different use case depending on your
device that you are using these
techniques on it it provided different
flows a couple of flows that you might
uh hear is au code flow authorization
code flow for server side apps server
side apps second implicit flow implicit
flow for browser based apps which is now
discouraged due to security risks third
client credentials flow for machine to
machine communication machine to machine
communication like communication between
two servers without any involvement of
user or browsers or any human
interactions and fourth is device code
flow device code flow is used in in
devices where we have limited input
where we don't have uh inputs like
keyboards and Mouse and all for example
one of a major example is smart TV smart
TV authentication uses a flow called
device code flow okay and o 2.0 came
with all these features it came with bar
token and it came with all these
different types of flows for different
types of devices depending on where you
are implementing your authentication but
one thing that I missed to say here was
O was great for authorization was great
for authorization but but it did not
solve the issue of authentication so if
you remember authentication is providing
an identity saying who you are and
authorization is saying what can you do
what all permissions do you have what
all capabilities do you have in the
platform and authentication is who are
you in the platform what is your
identity what is your name what is your
ID and all and authorization is what is
your permission okay so o solved the
issue of authorization using delegation
but it did not solve the issue of
authentication so that's when in
2014 or so people came up with open ID
connect or simply called oidc which was
built on top of O 2.0's security
mechanisms to fill the gap of
authentication in the whole
authorization workflow so this is how it
works what oidc did on top of oath was
open ID connect extended o 2.0 by
introducing what you call it ID token we
did not have that in O 2.0 and the ID
token was typically a JWT we have
already discussed JWT for the reasons
for reasons like this because we will
keep coming across JWT is in multiple
areas of authentication and
authorization that's why we discussed
about jws in the initial part of the
video so what open ID connect did was it
introduced a concept called ID token in
the O 2.0 workflow
an ID token was nothing but a JWT which
had information like user ID when they
logged in which happened because of the
field issued at and the issuing
authority who issued the token who was
the authority who was the platform that
issued the token to this user and all
this information that was in the
JWT the JWT also had information like
the user's name and the users email and
all the information that the needing
party once from the other platform and
because of open ID connect now you can
go to any platform and major pretty much
all the platforms have this feature now
you can do sign in with Google sign in
with Facebook sign in with Discord and
those features use open ID connect
behind the scenes to take your identity
from let's say you do sign in with
Google so what happens is it takes your
identity your email and your Google
image your Google profile picture your
name and all whatever the profile
information it asks for it takes your
identity from Google and it stores in
their database or it just uses that to
identify you to authenticate you using
Google without having its own
authentication mechanisms so that's the
use of open ID connect it introduced a
layer of identification on top of O 2.0
so this is how a typical open ID connect
based workflow works works first thing
the client in this case so let's say you
went to a platform you went to a
platform for note taking the client and
you click on sign in with Google so this
client the not taking app it redirects
you to the authorization server we
discussed about authorization server
just before it redirects you to the
authorization server the user logs in
into the Google account since they did
sign in with Google they log Lo in using
the Google account from the Google's
authorization server not from the
client's server they do it from the
Google's authorization server they login
they provide whatever permissions that
was asked by the client for example
reading the users email or the name or
the profile picture whatever you grant
those permissions and the authorization
server sends two things a authorization
code an authorization code and an ID
token back to the client to the not
taking platform then what the client
does in the second step it uses the code
and an ID token is optional at this
stage in some workflows and when the
client uses the Au code the
authorization code in the Second Step It
exchanges the authorization code with
the server with the with the resource
server for a access token for a access
token on behalf of the user and an ID
token if did not get the ID token in the
first s it gets an ID token toen in the
second step and the ID token will have
jws and inside the JWT it will have the
users's ID users name different values
of the user and the access token using
the access token the not taking server
the client can do different different
operations on behalf of the user in the
resource server so now let's say the not
taking server asked for Google keeps
access okay all the notes that you have
in your Google keep it ask for that
access during the authorization workflow
so and you granted that access now when
everything is done it uses the Au code
to get this access token now the note
taking server can store this token this
access token and it can get all your
notes from Google server using this
access token on behalf of you now that's
the use of open ID connect now the
client platform the not taking platform
can authenticate on behalf of you it can
pose as you it can appear as you to the
Google server and it can ask for stuff
whatever the stuff it asked permission
from you not any uh kind of stuff only
the stuff it has permission for in this
case all the notes from your Google keep
okay that's how the whole workflow works
so you can imagine or 2.0 and open ID
connect together as security guards or
key makers of the digital age of the
digital Modern Age they ensure that no
one not a user or a platform gets more
access than they need or then they have
asked for in the first place from the
user so they only get access to those
resources that they have access for that
they have permission for and protocols
like o 2.0 and open ID connect make sure
that it happens it stays like that and
together these two revolutionary
technologies have transformed the
internet from a password sharing
chaos into a secure into a secure modern
interconnected system and because of
these two technologies we have so many
new features in so many platforms that
we can integrate one system into another
we can do different types of uh resource
sharing we can type do different types
of permission sharing and all those
different things that can happen because
of O 2.0 and open ID connect now the
question is when should you use which
type of authentication now that we
discussed the four major types of
authentication that we use uh in the
modern age that you should be aware of
as a backend engineer which technique
which type of authentication that you
use in which kind of situation so this
can help you decide on that so these are
some of the thumb rules stateful
authentication using a session ID or a
GW taken and a persistent storage you
use stateful authentication for
typically all your web app based
authentication work workflows uh which
comprise of pretty much a large portion
of our SAS based models right that's a
stateful authentication is ideal for
that kind of scenario where user
specific session data is stored on the
server okay State stateless
authentication is ideal for apis or
scalable systems which have distributed
servers all over the world and where
tokens carry users info or users data we
have o authentications
this is ideal for third party
Integrations and providing login via
external providers like Google Facebook
Discord and all we have API key based
authentication which is ideal for server
to server or machine to machine
communication or a let's say single
purpose client access to apis so that's
pretty much all the four kinds of
authentication and a simple thumb rule
to decide you on when to use what in my
experience you will use stateful
authentic and stateless authentication
most of your times when you're building
your apis okay and with that we have
pretty much talked about everything that
you need to know as a backend engineer
about authentication that you need to
understand about authentication and now
we can move on to authorization this is
not as vast as authentication but just
you can still get an high level idea of
what it is about as I have already
mentioned the the on line explanation of
of authorization is authentication is
basically the who which means who the
identity of the user and authorization
is the permissions of the user what a
user can do and authentication is who
the user is in the platform those are
the two questions that can help you
understand the difference between
authentication and authorization now
moving on to authorization what was the
need of it why did people come up with
this concept called authorization
circling back to our example let's say
we have a user that logged into our
system we have a server
and let's say it's a not taking platform
it's a not taking platform and the user
logged into our platform or logged into
our server using the appropriate
credentials so it provided the email or
password or whatever the credentials
need are and it authenticated itself
into the platform now it can create
notes it can delete notes it can update
notes whatever the typical function it
of a not teing platform is that's one
part second part comes is you as the
creator of this platform is a creator of
this platform you need to your platform
has an ability or let's say a delete
feature and the delete feature actually
does not delete the note permanently it
stores the note in kind of a recycle bin
or a trash can so the user has the
ability they can either delete it
permanently or it will will get
automatically deleted after 30 days
after 30 days let's say all these notes
move into another Zone they get deleted
for the user but it don't get
permanently deleted from the database
they move into another Zone let's call
this dead zone it all the nodes after 30
days they move into this Zone called
Dead Zone okay and now the requirement
is you as a creator of the note taking
platform you want to is these notes
programmatically using another UI called
admin UI so you are the administrator
you're the Creator UI or another UI
called Creator UI you as an
administrator of this platform or a
creator of this platform want to have
some permission some capability which
are not granted to all the users of this
platform which are not granted to every
user you want special permissions for
this platform and you want to create
another UI for yourself in for this case
one solution for that is one solution
for that is you can let's say come up
with a random string and you can send
the string with each API and using that
you can say that okay so uh the server
will identify that this is coming from
the Creator give the access to those
capabilities which are not accessible to
all the users now the problem with that
is this is this has security flaws since
you are sending this special string this
is this god mode string in your apis if
someone intercepts this string they get
hold of the string they can do a lot of
uh disastrous thing to your platform
they can entirely clean the DB they can
mess with other users data they can do a
lot of Stu there is a huge security risk
with this approach that is the first
part the second part is what if you want
to give the same level of access the
same level of special access to other
users other users let's say to your
friends are people who regularly
maintain the platform you want to give
them these special permissions so now
you have to either give that string to
them or you will create more strings and
add the support in your server to allow
for those strings for the special
permissions now as you can see the
system just got more complicated than it
was before and it is very difficult to
manage the access now and it is more
prone to security flaws use cases like
this use cases like this I have
oversimplified the use case but all in
all what you can see is
providing specific
permissions providing specific
permissions to specific users on a
platform is basically called
authorization what authorization means
is not all users in the platform have
the same level of access not all users
can do the can do the same thing some
users have different capabilities some
users have more capabilities some users
have less capabilities some users have
completely different set of capabilities
than the other users and if you're
building a multi-tenant architecture
let's say you are providing users to
create organizations and in that
organization you want users the admin to
provide different permissions to
different kinds of members so you want
to provide you want to provide the admin
the capability so that the admin can
assign read or write permission to some
users and only read permissions to some
users so because of the need of these
kinds of scenarios people came up with
authorization techniques and one of the
most famous ones that we use still in
the modern age that you as a backend
engineer should be familiar with is
arback which stands for role based
Access Control okay and it's called role
based access control because this this
is how it typically Works in a typical
platform we have different roles one can
be a user role it can be an admin role
it can be a moderator role we have
different roles and different roles are
assigned different set of permissions
let's say a user role is only assigned
read permission admin role is assigned
read and write permission same way a
moderator role is only assigned read and
write permission depending on the role
and you can create create your own
custom roles with own with its own set
of permissions on different different
kinds of resources let's say a notes
users have read write and delete but on
a different resource let's say accessing
The Dead Zone notes that permission is
only provided to admin you can go as
granular as you want using different
roles and permissions and that's all
there is to it in our back and
authorization so this is how a typical
workflow works so in a platform a user
registers or a user signs up and the
server assigns it a role let's say it
assigns it a user role or depending on
the use case it assigns it a admin role
and in the subsequent request once the
user sends its token or it could be
session ID using stateful session ID
using stateful authentications or a JWT
using stateless authentication whatever
the means of authentication it is it
sends its identification
and the server can deduce what is the
role of the user using that token or it
can do a database lookup and see what
the assigned role of that user is
whether the role is user or the role is
admin and depending on the role of that
user that is deduced early in the
request cycle and it is passed on to the
next set of middlewares uh we'll talk
about middleware and how the middleware
chain works in the in a future video but
imagine in the first entry point the
server checks your uh your identity and
checks your role and it attaches that
information so that the next set of code
the next set of logic that next set of
logic can have access to this
information so that they can decide
whether whether a user has access to the
dead zone notes and the user will have
access to the dead zone notes if the
role is admin and if the user role is uh
user if the role is user then the API
will fail and it will the server will
send an error called forbidden with
status 403 which means you don't have
enough permission to perform this task
or access this resource that's the whole
idea of arback role based access control
and that's pretty much all you need to
know about authorization and our back
since we are talking about
authentication authorization and it's in
the context of back and Inus two things
that I want people to know these two
things
is sending appropriate error messages in
the authentication workflow and some
info about timing attacks so the first
thing error messages during the course
of authentication there will be
instances when you have to send messages
to the client the user logs in with a
certain email and you could not find
that email in your database and you send
a very helpful message called user not
found or let's say the email was found
but the password was incorrect so you
sent a friendly message called incorrect
password the same way the user tried
invalid credentials
for sometimes for invalid credential for
a few times and you send a message
account locked due to too many failed
attempts and while these messages are
helpful for legitimate users they also
provide attackers with clues for example
if the error indicates user not found
the attacker learns that the username
does not exist and if they're trying to
breach users some users account they
will move on to the next user they will
try with a different email and they will
keep moving on to the next users if they
have a certain list of users they that
they want to breach the same way if you
send a message called incorrect password
now the attacker knows that the username
was correct and now they only have to
breach the password so they will try a
list of brute passwords using brute
forcing or dictionary attacks and they
will there attack surface will increase
because they had some kind of
confirmation from you as a server as a
backend engineer you should be aware
that never send specific messages when
it is about authentication right never
send friendly messages like these always
keep any message related to
authentication generic so you can do you
can save authentication failed you can
do authentication failed for all the
three cases does not matter what happens
what kind of uh authentication failure
happens always send a generic message to
the client so that the attacker is
always uh confused if if it's an
attacker it's confused that what is the
next set of actions it they should take
to breach the system that's one
important thing you have to remember
always send generic error messages
during your authentication workflow
during your authentication life cycle do
not send friendly client friendly or
user friendly error messages
particularly in this workflow you can
send user friendly error messages during
other workflows like validations or
other apis in the security World there
is another kind of attack even though it
is rare it is called a timing attack and
how it works is in a typical
authentication workflow when the user
submits their credential the email and
the password first the server verifies
the the username or the email or the
username whatever it is provided for the
first field it verifies it if it tries
to find if it exists if the user exists
in the platform then the next step is if
they are handling it they check if the
account is locked or if the account is
suspended for a few time because of a
couple of invalid credentials that the
user has tried with in the near past so
servers have this mechanism where they
lock a a particular user account for
some time for 2 minutes or 4 minutes or
a day if they try too many invalid
authentication attempts so the second
step is first step is find user second
step is check if they are locked okay if
they are not locked third step is
comparing the password the provided
password with the stored hash the stored
hash that the server has stored in the
database because passwords are not
stored in plain text when you sign up
into a platform your password is taken
they're hashed into a particular
cryptographically safe string then they
are stored in the database and there is
no way to get the plain text value of
that password even for the server right
the server can only encrypt that
password in into a particular string and
then it can store that password so that
so that the next time you provide your
password it can compare it can hash that
password it can encrypt that password
into the same form it can fetch the
previously stored password from the
database and then it can compare those
two that's the way servers check if the
password is correct or not that's the
typical workflow of checking if the user
has provided correct password or not
they take the provided password they
hash it using the same algorithms using
the same key and they check that version
with the stored hashed version in the
the database and they check if they are
same or not they're not same then the
password is incorrect okay that is the
third step check password and now the
problem here is if the username is
invalid if the username is invalid in
the first step the system will terminate
there only and you will get uh some
response that user not found and that
will have a faster response time as
compared to the system failing at the
third step at the third step where
username is is valid but the password is
incorrect In this case the response will
have some kind of delay because it
failed in the third step and the system
will take a little longer due to the
additional step of hashing the password
hashing the password takes a little
longer than doing the other operations
that's why if the username is invalid
the system will have a faster response
if the password is invalid system will
have a little delay in the response and
use using that parameter that delay
whatever 200 milliseconds or whatever
the delay is attackers can can find out
whether that username was correct or not
or at what step the server failed to
authenticate and they can find if the
usern name was invalid or the password
was invalid and they can use this
strategy and they can use this
information to further strategize their
attack plan they can decide whether to
Target on the username or to Target on
the password based on brute force or
dictionary attacks and all so what you
can do is as a backend engineer to
defend against these kinds of timing
attacks you can you have to make sure
that authentication systems must
introduce measures to equalize the
response times one method you can use is
constant time operations there are some
cryptographically secure constant time
comparison functions for password hashes
these functions ensure that execution
time does not vary based on the input
similarity that is one method you can
use the second method that you can use
this you can simulate a response delay
uh using whatever programming language
that you're using if you're using node
just you can do set timeout or if you're
using goang you can do time do sleep so
you can do a simulation so that even in
case of username not matching the system
does not send a response immediately it
simulates some kind of response like 200
milliseconds of delay and then send a
response so that the attackers cannot
measure the timing differences between a
username failing and a password failing
because you are simulating a fake delay
but these are the two major kinds of
security related information that you
should have in mind while you are
implementing authentication and
authorization and with that that's all
about authentication and authorization
that you should know as a backend
engineer and in the next video we will
move on to validations and
transformations